just as we move on to part two and it
won't take long it's like a line and
then you're going to move on into
breakouts let me just highlight how much
additional working and language is used
symbolic language is used around this
that actually makes the proof clear
right even things like let's talking
about what conditions your numbers meet
you know this kind of little explanation
over here about why you can say that
these things are integers because you
can't just assume them all of that and
then my conclusion
even my use of a little therefore symbol
like that all of these kinds of things
are classically missed in all the
solutions that we've seen written by you
guys because you focus on the part that
seems like it's taking a lot of the
cognitive load in terms of like i'm
thinking about the algebra right and
it's true like this stuff is really
important but you guys know because
we've said it till you know you guys get
sick of hearing it that working
mathematically is not just about
crunching numbers and algebra it's about
uh problem solving and reasoning and
fluency which you just saw but also
communicating and all of this stuff that
you can see here in green is kind of
additional to just doing the algebra
right so pulling out a result like this
yeah hearty approval um but make sure
you have all these other parts that show
how the logic fits together okay
so i hope that is clear um and more
slightly more of a um a tangent than i
intended to take but i hope it was a
helpful one
all right part two um for the number of
you who are kind of thinking yeah tell
me again what a contrapositive is let me
help you remember um we've i've stated
or i've kind of annotated here um i've
called this part of the statement a or
this part of the proposition is the
language that the question uses and i've
called this part b
so if a
implies b
a implies b
is our original statement then our
contrapositive i wonder if you remember
um requires us to do kind of two things
right the contrapositive it takes both
of your um a and your b and it negates
them right so it's not a and not b that
we're dealing with and then it switches
the order right so it sends it backwards
so it would be
if this is p let me move this over
if this is p
then the contrapositive of p
is going to be
it's a very long word to write not b
implies not
a so once you know what a and b clearly
are then doing this like in words is all
you need to do to get the one mark for
this question right it just says write
down no more reasoning is required okay
so i'm going to do that i'm going to
negate each statement and say them
backwards so here is b
k q plus 1 is divisible by 3 so the
negation of b would be k cubed plus one
or i should have an if out the front in
fact if k cubed plus one
is not divisible by three there we go
there's not
b
i'm now going to imply so i say then
and i look back at my a statement so
there it is k plus 1 is divisible by 3
so i want not a so i'm just going to say
k plus 1
is also not divisible by three
okay
so
that's it part two finished one of the
easiest marks in the entire paper but it
then gets followed by three of the
hardest ones so as promised we're going
to send you into breakouts in a second
probably six or seven minutes okay
you're welcome to start writing a
solution but the thing that i want to
emphasize is this is not about um how
you're actually going to present your
solution i want you to think through
how to actually structure the solution
okay now maybe it would be helpful um
before i send you into breakouts to just
give you one more clue which is just to
make sure you understand you're all on
the same page about the language of the
question
it says part three
write down the converse of the
proposition p and state with reasons
whether this converse is true or false
so obviously the key idea here that's
introduced which we haven't had to look
at in the rest of the question is this
converse idea
and you know this is an important thing
to kind of stop at because the whole
issue here is if you've got a statement
that's true which we've just shown
proposition p is true we just proved
that in part p
um the converse of that statement may or
may not be true so part of this question
and what makes it i think challenging
why so much of the state did poorly on
it is they don't tell you whether this
thing is true or false you've got to
identify whether it's true or false and
then prove whichever one it is right
now let me just remind you that there's
a couple of really obvious examples of
when a converse can be true and when it
can be false right so a classic one i
think is that if you have a right angle
triangle of any description as long as
you've got a right angle triangle then
you can know that its sides are going to
relate in this particular way the sum of
the squares of the two shorter sides
equals the square of the hypotenuse
pythagoras theorem but importantly the
converse of pythagoras theorem is also
true if you get handed some random
triangle and you have a look at its
sides and you can say oh three four and
five it looks to me like a squared plus
b squared equals sorry i wrote a
right angle there a terrible right angle
for no reason if you know that those
sides have this a squared plus b squared
equals c squared relationship that
implies back in the opposite direction
that this is a right angle triangle so
pythagoras theorem is true
and its converse is true
but there are loads and loads of
statements that are true and their
converse is not for example if you have
a four-sided figure and you know that it
is a square
then that implies that that same figure
is also going to be a rectangle which is
to say all of the angles are 90 degrees
being a square implies that you are a
rectangle but the converse is not
necessarily true just because you've got
a shape that's a rectangle all the
angles are 90 degrees that doesn't mean
it's also guaranteed to be a square even
if it is some of the time so in this
case the converse is false so here's
going to be your first job when you get
into this room right
how are you going to determine like is
this true or is it false um what thought
process will you go through because the
question's not telling you and then once
you've settled that can you come up with
a nice way or two or three even of how
to actually prove whether it's true if
it's true or it's false if it's false so
my clock says 2 34. i'm going to ask you
all to get into your breakouts for the
next
six minutes um and we're going to wander
around mrs lees and i to have a look and
if you've got any issues or questions or
you're like we're so done um just let us
know
let's just make sure we're in the same
spot here right you remember the
question is asking you a couple of
things it says write down the converse
which i'm about to go through that in a
second and then state with reasons
uh which should be cheeky right state
with reasons because state usually means
like just tell me um don't worry about
reasoning and then it says then tell me
with reasons right
state whether this converse is true or
false they're trying to avoid some weird
language around prove the thing true if
true prove the thing false if false so
that's that's what's going on here okay
now in some of the breakouts well i
think i made it to most breakouts that i
chatted to my first question to you was
do you think this is true or not because
you don't want to spend a whole amount
of time proving that this is true if
it's actually false or vice versa right
so the first question you have to settle
for yourself and a lot of the state
didn't even make it past this hurdle is
is the statement true or false right so
the way that i went about this because i
i gave a real go before looking at
anything like a solution was
i need to kind of well i need to test
some numbers right i need to get a vague
sense of am i heading in the right
direction is it is it likely to be true
or can like all i need is a single
counter example and then i can know oh
it must be false sometimes which means i
can't prove it true for all values of k
right so what i just thought is i'll try
some values of k and see what happens
and i need to cube these numbers and
then add one right so one cubed is one
you add one you get two
two cubed is eight so that goes to nine
three cubed is 27 so it gets 28
uh 64 turns into 65 what's this 125
turns 126 216 turns in 217
7 cubed that's 343 so i get 344 here and
then 8 cubed 64 times 8 that's 5 12. so
i'll add 1. so this is what i get right
now when i have a look at this i can say
well which one of these which ones of
these are divisible by 3 and it's not
too hard to verify right you're like
well that's divisible by three uh that's
divisible by three and then um 513 is
five plus one plus three so it's nine so
yeah that's that's divisible by three so
these are the ones right and importantly
importantly none of the other ones are
two is a dud 28 65 217 344.
now even though these are all duds right
it's very important to test these
because these
could have given us a counter example
because when you have a look at what is
k plus one then you do uh snow soon
notes and surprises here get three six
and nine so k plus one is divisible by
three in each of these cases but you
couldn't test just three and six and
nine or i should say two and five and
eight because you'd be missing
the possibility of counter examples
right you'd only be testing in this
direction from k plus one to k cubed
plus one we've actually got to test
everything here to make sure we know
whether it breaks or not now i haven't
obviously gone very far only tested
eight numbers this is certainly not a
proof but it's a helpful indicator that
the converse is probably true and it
would be enormously sadistic like
there's famous patterns that go for a
really really long time like sometimes
hundreds or thousands of millions of
numbers
and then they break
but it would be you know unfair to give
something like that to you in the
context of a time pressured exam so what
i think i'm going to try and do is prove
this converse here's my b part of the
statement and here's my a so if k q plus
1 is divisible then a k plus 1 is
divisible right
now how do we try and do this by a
direct proof how would that look right
well if k cubed plus 1
was equal to 3 times some number and
then that implies that therefore k plus
1 is also equal to 3 times some number
that's how i would go it go at it via a
direct proof right
but how do you even make progress on
this and i even saw some of the rooms
trying to like wrestle with this yeah um
how would we make progress with it
because you know you'd have to do some
kind of cube root operation to get like
you've got to do some algebraic sort of
operations to get from this to something
that looks like this and if you
introduce a cube root you're like i
don't know like k cubed equals 3 n minus
1 and so i guess you've got the cube
root of three n minus one
and then you you'd add one and i have no
idea what's going on there right uh even
though it's true uh at least i'm
assuming it's true if i know that this
antecedent clause is is sort of given
right